just to show like lighten up the mood
very funny anyway it goes on very good
maybe we'll get coffee yeah so you're
like a
it's you know you're like spock and
everyone is
around you is like bones you know the
character or the
yeah the the actual character right
it's like you come into my podcast you
bring your own headphones
yes you're the same thing you bring your
own mic yeah never had that happen
before crazy yeah
all right you wiped everything down i
respect it thank you
you know i'm wondering what it's like
when a lady makes
love to you do you put plastic over the
bed is it interesting it's
very surgical i have rules and i get
them out of the way really fast okay so
what are the rules
i'm a lady yeah i could okay let's say
we're david dating for a couple weeks
sure i decided and i've already got one
of you
we've been dating we've dated a couple
days i probably i'm about to [ __ ] you
okay okay so that this is
about the [ __ ] right right so i come
over to your house right
you've already gotten to know me so you
know it's cute when i say
take off your shoes and if we're going
to get into my bed you either need to be
naked or i'm going to give you shorts
because they know this already is that
what you say yes so you give them shorts
like basketball i give them options all
right basketball shorts
yeah or or like or um or by the way this
was a long long time ago and all of them
were uglier than betty better you're the
most beautiful girl i've ever been with
yeah
but or box the boxers that i don't wear
anymore but you know they're like
girls wear them as shorts you know they
do this thing yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like yeah and then they'll get in
bed and then like i'll say
alexa play rock and roll or whatever
yeah
yeah yeah put on one of my podcasts or
something well so you led zeppelin rock
and roll or just any rock and roll is
there any other rock and roll
there probably is a good touche go ahead
so play a little led zeppelin you know
smokey on the water or whatever
imagine listening to led zeppelin yeah
and uh and uh yeah so what's your
question now
so is it because you're so very clinical
and surgical about things
is there like okay now you're gonna lay
on your back spread your legs open
and i'm gonna insert here i mean how
does that work no i'm listen as ocd as i
am yeah
i also and i'm being i'm i'm not yes
um yeah i made that up by the way i
don't know i know my cousin's death
oh i'm it's okay you know let me finish
all right go ahead
i'm very excited to hear that we'd love
to get him on the pod
[Laughter]
you know what i've been wanting to do
i've been wanting to have somebody sign
in the corner of my living room the
whole podcast
could we get him on on your episode and
you can sign everything no he's in the
philippines
well we'll you know zoom in hey rick
would you ever have
um my girlfriend on your podcast don't
force me onto someone's channel oh
listen
i i i would love to have you on the
podcast
yeah i asked something that is very high
school
recently when esther was on mine because
we talked about you guys a little bit
i suggested you got to go on tiger belly
to promote your special yeah
talking about you i'd love to have iran
and at the time i don't remember if i
had deleted it or not but i did do like
uh hey
will you circ like i had esther ask you
what is it about you writing me and then
delete undoing the writing i i was wrong
and i feel like i'm a really
approachable person i don't know you
and through association i
you heard the messages i mess when i
message you
because of our relationship in that
moment it's now we have relatively
speaking our own
but it was only your bobby's girlfriend
respectfully i don't
i don't know you i didn't think you knew
who i was fair you know what i do
appreciate that
because some people don't they just some
people don't what
just go for it and i'm kind of like it
it felt a little
it felt it it would feel to ask you
without meeting you and
it's not necessarily the right but my
mindset is
oh i asked bobby bobby isn't maybe i
could get collide
and i didn't want to make it seem like
that and there's probably other things
that i could check in on i don't know
but
i would love to have you on the podcast
were you neurotic on the set of
undateable
i heard some things but you were just on
oh really what did you hear
that you were in the beginning of your
first show and there was a little neuro
neurosis going on on the show i def